якщо ми не дотягнемо цю війну то ви ж
розумієте що іншого шанса е у нас уже не
буде ми час набираємо людей які нам
потрібні були на вчора навіть не на
сьогодні 600 людей вбили їхніх Через два
дня там вже нові 600 людей у нас такої
можливості у нас на жаль такої
можливості нема у нас там 100 потеряли
20 прийшло а сейчас поміняемм главком ну
ну не проблема поміняйте на кого Ну хто
ще так витягне як не він його бачить так
Валерій Федоровича так бачать люди любий
посля нього назначений главком Мені дуже
буде независимо от того кого там на Мені
буде дуже жалко ту
людину якщо в прошлому році
Ну можна було ставити якісь прогнози То
цей тяжкий 23-й рік Він показав що ніякі
прогнози вони не срабатують Я розумію що
всі устали від війни всім тяжко Але ми
маємо розуміти що ми маємо це
перетерпіти вижити і зробити свою справу
для того щоб наші діти були
вільними сьогодні спілкуємося з
генералом ЗСУ очільником оборони
Миколаєва на початку повномасштабного
вторнення РФ в Україну а також людиною з
близького військового оточення
головнокомандувача ЗСУ залужного Дмитром
марченком Пане Дмитро Вітаю вас Пане
Дмитро наразі досить гостро стоїть
питання мобілізації в Україні Ось на
нещодавній підсумковій прес-конференції
президент Зеленський зазначив що від
військових є запит на ще 500 000
мобілізованих в Україні наразі яка яким
чином можна їх мобілізувати та в які
терміни ну це дуже там гостре питання
яке зараз стоїть ее на жаль ті
добровольці
які хотіли добровільно піти до лав
збройних сил для того щоб чинити оперру
вони закінчилися і ми побачили нову
проблему з якою не стикалися раніше
що
люди ну не не дуже розуміють е того
стану в якому опинилися ті хто воюють
уже два роки тобто люди виснажені їм
треба відпочити їм треба відновити
зусилля і для того щоб це зробити у нас
мають мають бути
резерви Я думаю
що спільними зусиллями з ее місцевими
органами самоврядування з поліцейськими
з військовими ми
такі зможемо донести до нашої чоловічої
половини України е ту інформацію що ну
ну потрібно потрібно чинити опір якщо ми
не дотягнемо цю війну то ви ж розумієте
що іншого шанса У нас уже вже не буде ну
от саме 500 000 людей от в які терміни
можливо їх мобілізувати ну це Звісно що
це буде не один день це будуть етапи це
будуть
е це буде чіткий розподіл Я думаю що в
генеральному штабі є на то ее Плани є на
то запити і ну якби е сказати точно коли
це буде І як якісно я не можу І я навіть
не знаю хто може це вам сказати Ну
наразі є
розуміння куди для чого і навіщо вони а
розуміння як це як це
здійснити фізично то розуміння пока Ну в
мене точно його немає на мобілізацію цих
500 000 українців потрібно 500 млрд грн
казав
президент на що саме у мобілізаційному
процесі необхідна така сума ну ви ж
розумієте що кожного солдата надо
одягнути його надо навчити його надо
накормити тобто ці кошти вони саме для
того щоб обичної цивільної людини
зробити бійця який впевнено Буде себе
вести на полі бою а це це досить
недешево коштує і ми це всі розуміємо
повернуться бійці е на відновлення їх
надо одягнути їх надо відремонтувати
техніку їх надо накормити їх надо
полікувати це тоже кошти
Угу Тобто це цілий комплекс Який Ну Має
бути виконаний якщо ми його не виконаємо
то я не знаю що буде завтра ви ж бачите
що як ми несеммо втрати так і ворог несе
ворог несе дуже великі втрати але ворог
навчився їх дуже бистро поповнювати і ми
маємо робити так щоб не відставати в від
цих темпів А зараз відстаємо зараз на
жаль трошки відстаємо Угу Верховна Рада
підтримала зниження порогу
мобілізаційного віку з 27 до 25 років
президент поки що не підписав
законопроект На його думку там
недостатньо аргументів у цього рішення
ви як військова людина як ставитесь до
такої ініціативи Ну я ставлюсь дуже
позитивно тому що ну ви ж розумієте коли
йдуть
ее чоловіки віком 50-55 років а в той
час
25тирічні хлопці ну
не мобілізуються це не не дуже
справедливо тобто 25 років це це і є той
Той стан людини любого чоловіка як
кажуть в розсвіті сил
і якщо ви подивитесь на тих хто воює з
того боку то там основна маса - це
молоді хлопці ми розуміємо з ким ми
воюємо це переважаючі дуже переважаючі
сили і ми мали бути до цього готові ми
мали мали про це думати і ну це вкрай
необхідний просто захід Угу Чи
підтримуєте ви ідею мобілізації жінок в
Україні Ну я скажу так за бажанням якщо
жінка бажає то вона може призватися якщо
вона не бажає но закривати дирки жінками
в той час коли куча чоловіків ховається
десь за кордоном Ну я не знаю як вони
потім повернуться і будуть цим жінкам
дивитися в очі
Ну але жінки які вже їх досить багато
воюють на фронті ефективно себе
показують Так є і такі жінки які можуть
п підняти чоловіків і повести в бой ну
тобто є жінки ви ж розумієте що
ну ставить жінку на
рівень там бійця штурмового підрозділу
ну це не дуже правильно але Ну тому що
там є дуже сильні фізичні навантаження
які На жаль ну ви ж розумієте що жінка
не може пробігти 10 км там з 40 кгми на
плечах тому крім крім того що ми
штурмуємо в нас ще є дуже багато е
таких
обов'язків
роботи яка не потребує там значних
фізичних зусиль саме там вони можуть
себе проявляти як як дійсно як
професіонали як люди які потрібні Ми не
можемо порівнювати з Ізраїлем тому що у
них це на законодавчому рівні вже не
перший рік тобто вони перед тим як
призивати дівчат і жінок вони їх дуже
потужно готують і це в них відбувається
постійно постійні ротації постійні
навчання Е то то есть в нас геть інша
обстановка в нас геть інші віднос
відношення до цього А чи є рекрутинг в
ЗСУ дієвим у процесі мобілізації от
наразі ну рекрути є е але На жаль ми
маємо
час об'єднати всі зусилля військових
цивільних силових структур не для того
щоб там виходити на вулиці і ловити цих
військових а для того щоб
пояснювати що це обов'язок кожного зараз
захищати свою свою домівку треба Ну
треба трошки поміняти підхід робити на в
да час якусь реформу призову там
чи процесу мобілізації Ну я думаю що це
не дуже вчасно тому що ми розуміємо що
ми час набираємо людей які нам потрібні
були на вчора навіть не на сьогодні і
тому ви ж розумієте що кажда реформа
Вона може відбутися А може і не
відбутися тому ризикувати на даний час
там тім вчилася потом Вибачте не не
вийшло Ну ми ми не маємо права
головнокомандувач ЗСУ Валерій залужний
зазначив що воєнкоми у регіонах яких
масово звільнили цьогоріч у серпні цитую
були професіоналами Вони знали як це
робити тобто мобілізувати а їх немає
володіючи ситуацію зокрема от на півдні
ви бачите от як звільнення цих воєнкомів
можливо вплинуло на
мобілізацію так я відчуваю Я це не те що
відчуваю я це бачу на жаль воєнком ее це
така дуже специфічна Професія це нельзя
просто взять любого там Майора або
підполковника призначити і сказати в З
сьогоднішнього дня ти будеш воєнкомом і
ти маєш робити ту складну роботу так
були певні проблеми Так там дуже була
розвинута корупція але для цього є
відповідні органи які мали з цим
боротися ну тобто знімати Тобто ви ж
розумієте що не всі були поганими
воєнковами погані люди вони є всюди вони
є і і були і будуть і навіть серед цих
яких нових попризначали повірте мені що
будуть випадки коли вони будуть
займатися неправомірними діями але для
цього є відповідні органи вони мали з
цим боротися Ну просто так знімати всіх
професіоналів назначати туда просто
людей з збоку Ну я думаю що це не
вирішить проблему Вони ж не вкрали вчора
або согодні або на прошлому тижні вони
це робили роками і роками хтось на це
закривав очі Ну середи інших були і
професіонали які не займалися цим ми
мали зробити так щоб вони не крали і не
брали хабарі оце ми мали зробити це дбр
це СБУ це прокуратура Ну але загалом ось
ці нові та зміни та нові воєнкоми вони
справляються з тими потребами
мобілізації Ну ми це ми побачимо коли ми
будемо набирати ту кількість людей яка
нам потрібна але але на зараз Ну ви
бачите що відбувається Це оці походи по
містах це заходи в квартири в часні
сектора до людей додому ну це точно не
не їх обов'язок і вони точно не мають
цього права робити але вони змушені тому
що ви ж розумієте що змушені керівники е
поповняти втрати вони
Ми змушені це робити якщо ми ць не
будемо робити то рано чи пізно
ее в зв'язку з втратами підрозділи
будуть закінчуватись і в зв'язку з цим
будуть втрачатися території цього ми не
можемо допустити ви не раз публічно
заявляли що не хочете коментувати
наявність візійного конфлікту між
генштабом і офісом президента Чому так У
нас в державі відбувається війна і зараз
ми за саме зараз ми маємо е бути
мудрішими сильнішими і уміїшими і ми
зараз маємо не про конфлікти думати А як
сісти всім за один стол спланувати і
відбити ворога Я не хочу ніяких
конфліктів я скажу що для мене 24го
числа була прочерщена отак от червона
лінія і почалася Жизнь без політики без
якихось там вподобань без без нічого Я
думаю що хватить у наших
керівників на високому рівні
мудрості ну зробити так щоб не було
ніяких конфліктів на самом деле я думаю
що конфлікт він не столько є конфлікт
скільки його роздувають тому не проблема
сісти пожати руки і йти далі бити ворога
і Я рахую що цим саме і мають вони
зайнятися закінчиться війна потім будь
ласка
[музика]
розбирайтеся це в нас Херсонський
дизайнер есть тоже такий telegramканал і
він відтворює то як воспринимають нас
Люди прислав мені Валерія Федоровича
кажуть От йго бачить так Валерій
феодоровича так бачать люди він я вам
скажу він такий доволі буває жорстким
ее доволі иногда м'ягким тобто в нього
цей баланс він видержаний і це Ну це в
принципі дуже добре ну мені тяжело Я
представляю як йому тяжело Ну то то то
що він на себе взяв Це дуже велика
відповідальність от сечас кажуть там
типа сечас поміняемм главком ну ну не
проблема поміняйте на кого Ну хто ще так
витягне як не він я вам скажу що любий
посля нього назначений главком Мені дуже
буде независимо того кого там назнаю
мені буде дуже жалко ту людину тому що
він буде обречн що кажду його дію будуть
розбирати по запчастям Если до цього вже
всі звикли если цей там в самий тяжкий
час проявив себе і
удержав нашу країну то Ну де дещо йому
можуть простити то новому що кого
назначать йому не прочати нічого не
булить нещодавно стало відомо про
прослуховування кабінету головкома
залужного ви спілкувалися з ним про це і
Хто б це міг бути я спілкуюся злу з
Валері федросм сугуба по моїй роботі по
ну по тому що я
час роблю на півдні України Українська
правда посилаючись на на свої джерела у
спецслужбі Щодо цієї теми стверджує що
прослужку також виявили у кількох
підлеглих Валерія Федоровича ви є серед
них та я якось знаєте коли
людина просто собі працює робить свою
справу Чесно Ну хай прослу прослуховують
мені нема що ховати я ну я не займаюсь
якимись там неправомірними діями я
ніяким чином час не задіяний ні до яких
коштів і ні до яких закупівель е якщо
стоїть прослушка то тут якби є один
єдиний е допустим негатив Це хто Хто це
прослуховує і чи не вилізеть та
інформація яка мається на цьому
прослуховуванні далі І не буде якоїсь
утечки інформації Ну до нашого до нашого
ворога я ну я за це Тільки переживаю Ну
а от якщо діснослужки Ну так кажного
кожного держслужбовця можуть
прослуховувати і кожний розуміє що якщо
він там займає певну посаду ну це в нашй
час наверно неизбежно Ну ви не знаходили
у себе за час повно я їх не шукав якщо
хтось слухає то Ну Вибачте якщо я
там висловлююсь нецензурно вран я
виконую ті Заходи які залежать від мене
то есть я постійно міняю місце мешкання
місце роботи ну для того щоб ви
розумієте це необхідні заходи але ну
проводити на кожному місці там якісь там
перевірки прослуховування Ну я думаю
воно мені не потрібно щодо корупційних
скандалів у Міноборони за очільництва
міністра резнікова ви казали що причина
була цитую у поганому оточенні міністра
після кадрових змін у міністерстві от як
на вашу думку працює от нова зібрана
команда Ну поки що рано казати Як працює
Нова команда ми це Побачимо по
результату їхнії їхньої роботи як
мінімум через рік тому Ну Я думаю
неправильно буде там оцінювати людину
яка тільки ну тільки начинає розбиратися
в тому що їй довірили все це ми
побачимоче через рік так само ви
вважаєте щодо питання чи вирішилась
проблема корупції з приходом нових
обличчя Ну я не знаю цим цим мають
займатися компетентні органи Ну я не
можу давати таку оцінку добігає кінця
2023 рік другий рік повномасштабної
війни в Україні наразі українські та
іноземні посадовці войначальники
експерти дуже по-різному називають той
етап віни на якому ми перебуваємо і
кризовий етап і
вирішальний навіть глухий кут як на вашу
думку можна правильно назвати цей етап
війни з РФ в мене були там якісь Мої
особисті там думки Ну
але ну дуже дуже тяжко час назвати на
якому етапі ми знаходимося дуже тяжко
якщо в прошлому році
Ну можна було ставити якісь прогнози То
цей тяжкий 23-й рік Він показав що ніякі
прогнози вони не срабатують я можу
проаналізувати те що робиться на моєму
напрямку на напрямку час дуже тяжкий
етап але давайте ми не будемо
підсказувати нашому ворогу наші війська
морська піхота піхота артилерія то есть
ми е відбили
провздар зайшли закріпилися там що буде
далі Ну ви будете спостерігати
командувач угрупування військ Таврія
генерал Тарнавський нещодавно розповів
що ЗСУ скоротили деякі військові
операції через нестачу артснарядів та
іноземної допомоги по всій лінії фронту
наскільки ситуація критична саме на
вашому південному напрямку я не відкрию
військової таємниці якщо скажу що нам ну
дуже не хватає артилерійських снарядів
На жаль Ну це воно так есть але ну ну в
любих
умовах ми пристосовуємося до того що
маємо тобто у нас нема артилерійських
снарядів ще за допомогою волонтерів ми
ста Ми поставили акцент на fпіввічні
дрони тобто вони виконують задачу
артилерії і навіть на деяких напрямках
краще ніж артилерія тому Ну не будуть
снаряди ми будемо пристасовуватися не
буде У нас е не буде в нас тяжкої
техніки ми будемо пристасовуватися ми
будемо міняти плани ми будемо міняти
тактику ми будемо міняти підхід до до
виконання бойових задач Ну але ну Нам
нічого не залишається Ну ми будемо
стояти ми будемо воювати Ну але наразі
Та потуга той ресурс який є в армії РФ
дає їм можливість просунутись найближчим
часом десь на якихось
ділянках ну
ті сили і засоби які ми бачимо які час
перекинуті на по лінії фронту то есть їх
достатньо на проведення якихось
штурмових дій
але їх недостатньо допустим для там
захоплення Миколаєва або там захоплення
Харкова або захоплення Запоріжжя Я знаю
що сама основна
задача це на сході України вийти на на
адміністративні кордони або захопити хоч
якісь міста щоб Ну щоб у
них щоб
показати в оправдання цієї війни своїм
людям що у них є Які якийсь
успіх Я знаю що на півдні у них стоїть
задача хоча б не втратити те що вони вже
мають але ну я ж не розумію їхніх
стратегічних планів возможно завтра вони
приймуть рішення що їм потрібно захопити
Запоріжжя Миколаєв і Одесу і ми маємо до
цього готуватися
зараз маємо це тоже прораховувати ми
маємо час строїти три лінії оборони ми
маємо робити фортецю і зміст ми маємо до
цього готуватися угу у Контрнаступ у
2022 році завершився деокупацію
північних регіонів Харківщини
Правобережжя Херсонщини цьогоріч генштаб
визнає що Контрнаступ в 23му не
виправдав тих очікувань звільнити решту
території що відрізняло ці два
контрнаступи Ну по по характеру ведення
бойових дій Тобто ви розумієте що ка
кожне кожне ведення бойових дій воно має
свою назву Це або рейдові дії або
контрнаступальні дії або оборонні дії
і відповідно до кожних із цих дій є
певний перелік заходів які
проводяться тобто ну ж понімаєте
Контрнаступ - це підтримка з воздуха це
артилерійська підготовка це штурмові дії
ну це ну це такий дуже потужний ее дуже
потужний комплекс заходів який
проводиться для того щоби ну пробити
лінію оборони угу а тоді це було біше
тоді тоді це не відбувалося по одной
простой причині тоді не було лінії
оборони у Російської Федерації тобто
вони наступали вони не оборонялися для
того щоб нам відбити їх і гнати далі Нам
потрібні були ресурси яких у нас на той
час на жаль не вистачало в 22-му році я
маю на увазі в 23му році
там планувались дуже правильні хороші
контрнаступальні дії але на жаль для
того щоб їх проводити ми маємо розуміти
що в нас має бути достатньо артилерії
достатньо бронетехніки достатньо ПВО і
достатньо авіації якщо щось із цього
недостатньо то ви ж розумієте що цей
контрнасуп Він не буде таким ну вдалим
прогнозованим як має бути якщо чогось із
цього немаєгу але не мали на момент
контрнаступу і ви рішили спробувати Ну
так ми не рішили спробувати Ми змушені
були це робити тому що ви ж розумієте що
Люба любе
затіще Люб
наші наша
бездіяльність вона дає їм право
переформовувати під розділи
закріплятися строїти оборонні рубежі і
Саме основне - це не дати ворогу нас
взяти у кільце у щільне кільце як вони
зробили це в Маріуполі і ми з цією
задачею справились екс-командувач армії
США у Європі Бен годжес раніше
прогнозував що ЗСУ військовим
шляхом звільнять Крим влітку 23го року
але за умови вчасного надання західної
зброї попри затримку озброєння він досі
переконаний що Крим деокупують військо
шляхом ви поділяєте цю думку зараз ну
звісно поділяю я військовий Я розумію що
всі території нашої держави ми будемо
звільняти військовим шляхом якщо може
відбудеться чудо і Путін помре тоді може
щось поміняється але поки що ми
настроєні на те що звільняти наші
території військовим шляхом Ну я не знаю
ви ж Розумієте це людина яка не признає
помилок яка не признає ошибок яка не не
признає програшів Тобто вона назад точно
не здасть у них в принципі все
поставлено на ці військові рейки і воно
все йде собі своєчасно тобто на на
запорожському напрямку вони там е 600
людей вбили їхніх Через два дня там вже
нові 600 людей у нас такої можливості у
нас на жаль такої можливості нема у нас
там 100 потеряли 20 прийшло На жаль
ми це і є основною проблемою зараз там е
включати якихось експертів і там
розказувати що ви там погано спланували
що ви там неправильно працювали що ви
там нето ну тобто є
там є факти і фактори які на це
впливають на жаль і це точно не проблема
планування або командування влітку ви
розповіли в одному з інтерв'ю що як
генерал на півдні наразі співпрацюєте з
українськими партизанами на окупованих
південних територіях ця співпраця триває
зараз так це ну це дуже У нас дуже
плотна робота я ж говорю що є у нас
такий Telegram канал раніше він був
більш Південний сечас Наскільки я
розумію він жор такий став національного
масштабу це николаївський виньок це
людина яка дуже щільно і плотно
спілкується і працює з людьми на тому
боці з проукраїнські налаштованими які
надають нам цінну інформацію і завдяки
цьому Ми вдало
е-е вдало наносимо вогневі враження по
переміщенню їхньої техніки під час
їхнього наступу Ну а з їхнього боку тут
е ще досі багато ось таких На жаль вони
тоже дуже быстро адаптуються вони тоже
роблять Такі ж самі telegram-канали Вони
теж залучають сюда проросійсько
налаштованих людей ну тобто ви ж
розумієте що південь України він ну якби
це не
звучала прикро але він більш
проросійський ніж інші міста України
тому тут є певна кількість людей їх
небагато але їх і
немало які в принципі чекають руский мир
ви генерал який успішно очолив оборону
Миколаєва під час повномасштабного
вторгнення РФ на його початку в чому
полягала тоді ваша тактика в кажному отг
в кажному селі були мисливці які з
головою з місцевою головою вони
слідкували навіть коли ми їх просили
навіть виїжджали дивили коли там вони
питалися обходити село там чи якусь
місцевість вони навіть виїжджали і
доповідали нам кількість техніки в якому
напрямку ну це нам давало перевагу в
тому що ми могли чітко переставити
вогневі засоби і вчасно відкрити
вогоньти Лері для того щоб вони то ми їх
не підпускали
навіть не дали їм понюхати Миколаєва
що в нас відбувалось на початку
вторгнення усь Миколаїв зайшли сначала
на цей аеропорт в цей в цей час тут уже
були побудовані з херсонського боку
побудовані колони тут стояла колона тут
стояла колона росіян росіян снігрівки
стояла колона втора осьо бачите тут
прямо все Це все що нам доповідали люди
Ми все наносили на карту це все
відтворено ну з тих подій тобто вони
були тут вони були тут тобто вони вже по
суті взяли нас в кільце О я вам скажу що
оборона Миколаєва вона Я рахую що вона
трошки
недооцінна в масштабах цієї війни в
Україні можливо наш спротив він і
зазмусив росіян уйти з
Києва але ризик був що вони от наскільки
велики що Ну я вам скажу чесно то тьго
по-моєму Березня я вже готував міста до
оточення Тобто я вже прийшов до Віталія
Кіма в сказав що нам надо робити запаси
води запаси єди боєприпасів топ палива
ну тобто ми вже готувались до боюв в
місті і до оточе до такого до плотного
оточення міста і дня вони мали за три
дня діти до Одеси е батальйонними
тактичними групами через поромні
переправи які вони мали положити три
штуки ну тобто операція на самом Делі в
них була така продумана досить потужно
але в Миколаєві в них щось пішло не так
успішну оборону Миколаєва часто
порівнюють з неуспіхом оборони на
сусідній Херсонщині які фактори завадили
вдало захистити от сусідні регіон я
скажу що одним із
ключових моментів чому це відбулося з
херсоном це місцева влада це місцева
влада це СБУ це люди які не чинили опір
які не готували
ні людей Ні ні війська ні силові
структури до спротиву ну це
просто спрацював план росіян
де вони зробили так що там вийшов мир
город і сказав не надо Ні з ким
сперечатися не надо воювати нічого
страшного ми маємо жити ми маємо не
вмирати і в
принципі основну роль зіграло саме це
Тобто Це була не непідготовленість а
свідома здача свідома здача Так я вам
скажу от як у нас відбулося по
вознесенську
Е голова одної з районних адміністрацій
сів на
танк російський і провів їх до
Вознесенська не пересікаючи жодної
дороги де уже були поставлені блокпости
де їх чекали а по полям їх завів в саме
місце просто так що їх не побачив ніхто
і Ми змушені вже були їх вибивати з з
міста я вам скажу Вони готували Миколая
до здачі Ну наскільки за повномасштабну
війну вдалося удосконалити тактику та
ефективність збройних сил України от
враховуючи все що вже було ну я Я рахую
що ми ще на етапі удосконалення те що
вчора ми рахували що воно найправильніше
найновіше найтехнологічніше вже сьогодні
Для нас це вже пройдений етап озброєння
ви маєте на увазі озброєння тактики
введення
е-е тактики підхід до підготовки ми
маємо дуже вчасно і дуже бистро
змінювати відношення до планування дій
відношення до проведення бойових дій і
більш ставити акцент не на людський
ресурс А
на високі технології це
розвідувальні дрони це дрони камікадз це
ну високоточне озброєння які
найвірогідніші сценарії розвитку війни в
Україні у 2024 році
перемога ну про інші ми просто не
думаємо угу у Ну але ЗСУ допускають інші
сценарії аби пропланувати і
підготуватися Ми готуємося до
найгірших найгірших сценаріїв але
надіємося на найкраще а найгірші
сценарій це які Ну давайте ми не будемо
сечас паніку наганяти
і не давати росіянам Потом це все
пере перекидувати на іпсо А скільки
взагалі таких сценаріїв Ну то що він не
один це 100% але ну ну їх і не таж і
багато ми прораховуємо всі ці випадки і
всі ці сценарії ми маємо до них бути
готові я ж говорю що поки в нас є
можливість нам надо зариватися нам надо
строїти оборонні рубежі нам надо
заливатися бетоном і робити фортеці
зміст щоб ворог розумів що ці міста їм
не пройти Наближаються
ріствяно-новорічні свята Що б ви хотіли
побажати і військовим і цивільним в
Україні у цей
час та я думаю що час у всіх бажання
одне це повернутися додому до своїх
сімей і ну в нашому випадку бути цілим
здоровим і живим Ой а цивільним я по
витримки побажав би витримки Я розумію
що всі всі всі устали від війни всім
тяжко але ми маємо розуміти що ми маємо
це перетерпіти вижити і зробити свою
справу для того щоб наші діти були
вільними Дуже дякую вам за цю
розмову